calcula la suma de todos los enteros
positivos de 27.000 y bueno 27.000 es el
número grandísimo así que hacer todos
los divisores se ve un poco difícil así
que lo primero que voy a hacer es tratar
de factorizar el 27.000 en primos para
ver de ahí cuántos divisores más o menos
tengo y ya con esto a ver que se me
ocurre así que tengo 27 mil en 7000 es
lo mismo que 27 por 1000 estás de
acuerdo 27 pues es 3 al cubo y 1000 es
lo mismo que 10 al cubo pero 10 al cubo
es lo mismo que 2 por 5 elevado al cubo
entonces deben ponerlo aquí esto es lo
mismo que 2 por 5
todo esto elevado al cubo y esto es lo
mismo que 2 al jugo por 5 al cubo
entonces si yo quisiera factorizar
27.000 en primos pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 2 al cubo por 3
al cubo por 5 al cubo ahora bien ya que
tengo aquí la descomposición de 27.000
en números primos lo que voy a hacer en
primer lugar es olvidarme un poco de
este 5 de este 5 al cubo voy a suponer
que no hay divisiones de 5 y voy a
intentar hacer una tabla para que quede
esto mucho más claro y veas más o menos
atrás lo que voy lo que quiero ahorita
se olvida de todos los divisores de
27.000 que tengan que ver con las
potencias de 5 por lo tanto vamos a
fijarnos primero en todas las posibles
potencias que tengo de 2 y bueno podemos
tomar 2 el acero pero 2 el acero es uno
entonces ya sabemos que uno divide a
27.000 dos al cuadrado es 44 también
divide a veces a 27.000 y 2 el cubo
estos 88 también divide 27.000 y vamos a
hacer lo mismo para el 31 espera espero
esperando esta falta de una potencia
2011 divide a 27 mil 2 a la 1 es 22
claramente divide 27 mil dos lados es 44
de vida 27.000 y 88 también que es 2 al
cubo y bueno vamos a hacer lo mismo con
el 3 vamos a agarrar las potencias del 3
partiendo del 0 y llegando al cubo
entonces me queda 3 013 al cuadrado es
93 el a1 es 33 al cuadrado es 9 y 3 al
cubo es 27 entonces aquí 9 y por último
tres por tres por tres lo cual es
ahora bien aquí lo que estoy haciendo es
construyendo una tabla y si te das
cuenta en esta tabla yo puede encontrar
varios divisores de 27.000 por ejemplo
si yo me agarro uno por uno
éste a su vez es un divisor de 27.000 si
yo me agarro uno por tres también o dos
por nueve o lo que sea de hecho vamos a
el primer renglón uno por uno es 11 por
33 me quedaría después uno por 9 lo cual
es 9 y 1 por 27 los cuales 27 y todas
las potencias que tienen que ver con el
3 pero también podría ser lo mismo con
el 2 con el 4 con el 8 puede tomar menos
por 12 2 por 3 6 9 por 2 18 y 27 por 254
este trabajo para el 4 para el 8 pero
para hacer un poco más rápido este vídeo
su puente que ya tengo toda la tabla
llena ahora lo que quiero analizar es la
suma porque realmente no me importan
todos los divisores lo que me importa es
la suma de todos estos divisores
positivos por lo tanto vamos a tomar
primero la suma de este primer renglón
que es 27 3 lo cual es 39 más uno es 10
y entonces 30 más 16 40 ahora fíjate
bien en algo bien interesante en este
segundo renglón a sea lo que
si yo me tomo la suma me estaría tomando
dos veces la misma suma que tengo aquí
arriba es decir 80 y aquí sería pues dos
veces la misma suma que tengo aquí
arriba porque lo que ustedes cientos
multiplicando por 2 por lo tanto la suma
de este tercer renglón sería 160 y de
este cuarto renglón sería 320 porque al
final me estoy tomando cada uno de estos
divisores primero multiplicados por 2
después por 4 que es 2 por 2 y después
por 8 que es 2 por 2 por 2 no sé podemos
tener por ejemplo aquí este cuarto
renglón no quedaría 8 por 18 8 por 3 24
8 por 9 72 8 por 27 160 más 8% 56 216
pero realmente no importa lo que importa
es que ya encontramos la suma de esta
tabla y de cada uno de los renglones de
esta tabla ahora bien recuerda que
estamos contando aquí que no tenemos 5
por lo tanto vamos a esta suma que
tenemos aquí me queda 40 más sabe mejor
más 160 es 280 más 320 es 400 400 más
200 100 600 perfecto esta es la suma de
todos estos renglones cuando
tenemos factores de 5 ahora dejemos
puntear eso aquí porque es bastante
interesante la suma de toda esta tabla
en 600 pero estamos contando con que
tenemos como factor a 5 a la cero por lo
tanto vamos a escribirlo aquí es 600 la
suma cuando tenemos no factores de 5
dicho de otra manera tenemos como factor
el 5 elevado a la 0 bueno ahora
imagínate que tenemos factores de 5
vamos a suponer primero que tenemos
solamente un factor de silicon todos
tendríamos todo todo multiplicado por 5
es decir al final me quedaría la suma de
600 también multiplicada por cinco pero
600 por 53 mil entonces la suma sería
3000 cuando tenemos solamente un factor
de 515 vamos a ponerle aquí cuando
tenemos 11 pongo un 5 me parece bien y
después veamos 25 después estaríamos
multiplicando otra vez por 5 y 3 mil por
5 es 15.000 entonces si tuviéramos 25 la
suma de toda esta tabla me quedaría 15
mil cuando tenemos 25 es decir 5 al
cuadrado y por último si tuviéramos
multiplica
por 5 por 5 por 5 es decir por 5 al cubo
tendríamos tres factores de 5 y me
quedaría pues 600 por 5 por 5 de otra
manera 15 mil por 5 y déjame apuntarlo
aquí entonces cuando tenemos 35 tenemos
de suma 15 mil por 5 lo cual es 15 mil
por 5 es como 75 mil 65 mil 5 por 5 25
75 mil claro 75 mil ahora bien ya
tenemos todos los factores cuando no
tenemos 5 cuando tenemos un 5 cuando
tenemos 25 cuando tenemos 35 y lo que
quiero saber es la suma de todos los
sentidos positivos divisores de 27 mil
entonces hay que tomar la suma de todo
esto y cuánto es la suma de todo esto
pues vamos a hacerlo aquí pues me
quedaría en 0 0 0 0 0 0 y después en las
centenas solamente tengo 6 después aquí
tengo tres más 55 me quedaría 13 y
llevamos una sí 3 si llevamos 17 y 18 y
19 93.600 y ya está la suma de todos
los posibles divisores de 27 mil 393
1600 espero que hayas encontrado esto
bastante interesante ya está la solución